دانت الخارجيه القطريه قيام ما قالت انها
قوات مسلحه غير نظاميه باقتحام وتخريب
مبنى سفرتها في العاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم
وشددت الخارجيه القطريه على ضروره تجنيب
السفارات والبعثات الدبلوماسيه تبعات
القتال الدائر بين الجيش السوداني وقوات
الدعم السريع
من جهتها دانت وزاره الخارجيه السودانيه
هجوم ما وصفتها بميليشيا الدعم السريع
المتمرده على مقر سفاره القطريه بالخرطوم
والعبث بمحتوياتها وسرقه المقتنيات دون
مراعاه للاعراف والقوانين الدوليه المعنيه
بحمايه الدبلوماسيين ومقاري البعثات
الدبلوماسيه ودعت الخارجيه السودانيه
المجتمع الدولي الى ادانه هذا السلوك
واعتبار الدعم السريع منظمه ارهابيه
وتحميلها المسؤوليه القانونيه والاخلاقيه
بحسب وصفها